David good morning how are you good
morning don't go that what so I'm doing
okay let's go back to 2010 when you when
you got that scholarship offer at the
age of 13 how did that change your life
um well honestly I mean at the time it
was so new to everyone and it didn't
happen really that much so no one not
not that many people do what to expect
and social media wasn't as big back then
and everything and and I went to a
school private school move it so it
wasn't it wasn't like you was you know a
lot of people really knew what was going
on but definitely got a lot of national
exposure and everything which you know
really really kind of made it seem like
it was it was bigger than what I thought
it was but um you know it really did
change my life a lot you know and put me
in the situation that I am now and
prepare situation now but I wondered and
I don't like when schools do this to a
kid who's in your kid you're 13 and you
know they said it was a real offer but
but it changes it may not change you as
much as it changes what others think of
you and now all of a sudden there's a
bull's-eye on you that all you're the
guy who got the scholarship at USC I was
wondering it did it affect your
development at all to get a scholarship
well for at 13 I definitely think it put
a target on my back coming up through
high school you know the service team
that we were we were playing against the
student section was always you know kind
of after me and and everybody kind of
wanted to take me out so it definitely
put a little bit of a target on my back
you know but I had really really great
parents that raised me and you know
taught me how to really you know no
matter what what's going on in your life
to be able to you know stay level-headed
you know and that's really what I think
you know kept me through you know what
the highs of you know getting offer in
seventh grade but being able to remain
humble through all of high school in
college but you go from being a
quarterback to a wide receiver
how tough was that decision to make
because it you know here's here you are
getting a scholarship at 13 to play
quarterback at USC and all of a sudden
you're trying to figure out another
position to play yeah it was really
tough at the time
you know when I got switched my my
freshman year I I didn't really want to
I I said I'd go play receiver you know
it helps the team but it's not what I
wanted to do and actually ended up
leaving West for Jane my freshman year
you know to go to go play quarterback at
his new college and you know it took me
a little bit to realize that I wasn't
going to be able to play Division one
college football at a high level at the
quarterback position and then after I
realized that it you know it took me a
little bit longer to realize then I
probably should have but once I realized
that I you know wasn't gonna be able to
to do that I was all in to play receiver
in you know that that's really what what
the last two years have been about but
you put up great numbers here that 33
touchdown receptions in the last two
years I mean that's that's impressive
where do you stand as far as the draft
goes because the last thing I saw was
maybe you'd be a third or fourth round
pick what are you hearing yes pretty
much around there as well you know you
you never really know what the teams are
thinking in house because that stuff
really doesn't get released much to the
media you know so it's tough because on
draft day guys on on other people's
boards end up going and then everybody's
scrambling for for what they need and
who they want so it's really tough to
tell you know now it's at a point where
I put in all the work did the Senior
Bowl to combine pro day and all the
interviews in between you know now it's
just time to wait and figure out where
you're gonna be playing and then be
ready for rookie minicamp because that
you know a lot of guys think that that's
touch it's not after pro day you can
kind of chill out for a little bit but
with the mini campus literally right
around the corner after you get drafted
he's David sells the former or West
Virginia white out best interview that
you had was with which team
ah I liked I liked my interview with
coach Tomlin down at the Senior Bowl met
with the the Steelers whole staff and
yeah that was that was a good interview
talks for about 30 minutes and
everything down there so you know he was
a really cool guy very personable so you
know talking to him was very well would
you run the 40 in Iran at four or five
seven all right it's not pedestrian did
where does that kind of it where does
that kind of match up with are you more
quick than fast you know I think I could
have ran probably a little bit of better
forty I was testing at a better for you
than what I had at the combine but you
know I think I'm able to build up speed
you know and there's so much technique
that goes into the forty that if you
breathe the wrong way then you're gonna
add two tenths to your forties though
you know it's it's a weird form of
measuring speed because it slow guys can
run fast and bad guys you know can can
run slow you know because it's all based
on technique and your start and
everything like that so obviously fast
guys have better chances to run fast
fast times but you know if your
technique is messed up and you're fast
you can still run a slow thought well
David good luck it's certainly been an
interesting journey and be nice to hear
your name called their weather not going
to be on Thursday but if you get the
call on Friday and get a chance to go in
and prove yourself again you've been
down this road before so good luck with
that we appreciate your time thank you I
really appreciate you having me on
that's David sills the fifth for more
Dan Patrick show tune in to audience
Channel 239 on DirecTV stream for free
on BR live or download the Dan Patrick
show app